we have some breaking news from
California where paradise is in ruins a
wildfire in that town of 27,000 people
north of Sacramento has destroyed an
estimated 2,000 or more buildings fire
officials believe some people were
killed and two more fires north of Los
Angeles are threatening tens of
thousands of homes forcing an emergency
evacuation overnight the so called camp
fire in Northern California covers more
than 20,000 acres and threatens another
15,000 or more structures it is
extremely dangerous this David beg no
discovered after officials escorted him
through the fire lines good idea ready
three two
David filed this report from the first
scene in Paradise California it has been
24 hours since the fire exploded here in
Northern California and it is still
windy that's a storage center behind me
that is burning and we've been hearing
explosions that's why we're walking away
listen over the last 24 hours there have
been harrowing accounts of people
literally abandoning their vehicles and
getting out to run for their lives
Heavenly Father please help us
surrounded by walls of flames whipped by
winds of 50 miles per hour people drove
through hell trying to escape their
homes and those of their neighbors burn
to the ground the camp fire exploded in
intensity filling the sky with toxic
smoke that could be seen from San
Francisco which is nearly a hundred and
fifty miles away we grabbed our animals
and some food and some foes and we're
getting the heck out of here there was
very little time for the 27 thousand
people who live in Paradise to evacuate
everything was ignited by the time I got
out of my house it was like everything
was on fire just after 1:00 a.m. Cal
Fire District Chief John Cox escorted us
into the town it is a disaster we saw
those cars that people abandon as they
felt trapped and decided to run some
people took refuge in concrete parking
lots which proved to be life savers
officials tell us firefighters use their
own shelter kits to shield civilians
from the flames we're talking devastated
that's Cal Fire Captain Scott McLean the
town center is completely on the ground
on the south side as well as the north
side has been hit very hard as well I
hope people got up I woke up all my
neighbor's got him out of bed next thing
you know their house is on fire I saved
their lives
Dwain D'Amico a retired engineer escaped
with his dog I don't think there's not
gonna be a home left in paradise I don't
know when I left it was all on fire so
we have spent most of the night riding
around this retirement community of
Paradise and I got to tell you most of
the town looks like it's been wiped out
Gail what we don't know is how many
people may have died in their homes
because they just couldn't get out fast
enough there's certainly more to come
guys when you look at that story and the
fact that it's called paradise or some
irony about that when you look at those
visuals we should point out again that
David was escorted in that situation